das was ein forschungsteam des
kernforschungszentrums cern jetzt plant
ist nicht nur exklusiv sondern auch
äußerst riskant der transport von
antimaterie in einem lastwagen
welches ziel dieses experiment verfolgt
und wie zerstörerisch dieser plan
wirklich ist das jetzt bei steaks und
science fiction ein video in
zusammenarbeit mit technology review
zum schluss habe ich übrigens ein großes
exemplar der wirklich kundschaft für
euch herzlich willkommen das war damals
vor 85 jahren eine echte sensation die
entdeckung der antimaterie seitdem
wissen wir für jedes teilchen gibt es
auch ein antiteilchen der elektronen ist
das zb das positron und nicht nur in der
natur ist das zusammenspiel zwischen
materie und antimaterie von großer
bedeutung heutzutage kann antimaterie
sogar künstlich erzeugt werden und ist
beispielsweise für medizinische
diagnosen äußerst sinnvoll der plan des
cern physikers alexandra bertelli und
seines teams aber lässt einem den atem
stocken
eine milliarde antiprotonen sollen in
einem container gespeichert werden und
einige hundert meter transportiert
werden um sie dann in einem anderen
experiment nutzen zu können
konkret soll die antimaterie auf schwach
radioaktive atomkerne gefeuert werden
dieses experiment habe ein äußerst
zerstörerisches potenzial so die
kritischen stimmen und antimaterie ist
eine echt exklusive sache dann nämlich
wenn sie auf materie trifft auf der
stelle löschen sie sich dann gegenseitig
aus 0,5 gramm antimaterie würden dabei
um reine energie zerstrahlen und auf
einen schlag ebenso viel energie
freisetzen wie die atombombe fat man die
hat im august von 45 die japanische
stadt nagasaki weitestgehend zerstört
die atombombe hatte eine sprengkraft von
21 kilotonnen tnt entwickelt das ganze
experiment verfolgt natürlich auch einen
sinn
das cern forschungsteam möchte ganz
konkret an die protonen mit neutronen
und protonen zur kollision bringt und
dann die entstehenden zerfallsprodukte
analysiert
denn seit rund zehn jahren weiß man dass
atomkerne nicht immer eine art klumpen
aus neutronen und protonen bilden
sondern auch neutronen wolken auch
halles genannt oder dichterin neutronen
schalen
das hatten forscherinnen und forscher
beispielsweise beim radioaktiven
beryllium entdeckt das kommt an der cern
experiment mit der antimaterie könnte
somit aufdecken ob es noch weitere
solcher kerner geht im besten fall
könnte sich damit sogar klären wie wir
uns ihr innenleben vorstellen können die
herstellung von antiprotonen ist für das
cern an sich nichts neues das gelingt
indem man schnelle protonen auf einen
massiven metall blog schießt
elektromagnetische felder brennen sie
dann stark sodass sie gespeichert werden
können durch ein vakuum werden die
antiprotonen dann von der umwelt
isoliert doch die von obertilliach
gesteppte größenordnung ist mit nichts
bisher dagewesene zu vergleichen
bislang liegt der rekord von antimaterie
experimenten bei 10 millionen
antiteilchen die man für kurze zeit
gespeichert hat das jetzt geplante
experiment dagegen sieht eine milliarde
vor wenn man das sehen das ist 100 mal
so viel der forscher selbst sieht das
gelassen ihre animation also das
zunichte machen würde seinen angaben
zufolge nicht mehr energie freisetzen
als man braucht um einen apfel
hochzuheben und weiter sei die
radioaktivität die dabei freigesetzt
würde verhältnismäßig gering
doch wie plant das cern forschungsteam
überhaupt diese gewaltige menge an
antimaterie zu stellen und über einen
zeitraum von einem monat zu speichern
genau hier liegt die große
herausforderung aber terry und sein team
wollen eine elektromagnetische falle
bauen die 70 zentimeter lang ist diese
soll dann im inneren eines
tonnenschweren super leitenden magneten
auf minus 269 grad celsius gekühlt
werden
das vakuum das verhindern soll dass die
antiprotonen mit luftteilchen in
berührung kommen muss dabei 100 1000 mal
dünner sein als das des lhc
beschleuniger falls dem forschungsteam
tatsächlich eine speicherung der
antiprotonen gelingt könnten diese in
einem fahrzeug dann zum benachbarten
labor transportiert werden wo das
anschließende experiment stattfinden
soll
denn wir
in der benachbarten isolde ionenstrahl
einrichtung würden die antiprotonen dann
mit den radioaktiven ionen kollidieren
oberteile und sein team die sind
jedenfalls optimistisch die entwicklung
einer solchen technologie könne ganz
neue wege in der forschung eröffnet
beispielsweise sieht der wissenschaftler
sie zukünftig als vielversprechende
antriebsquelle für die raumfahrt
vielen dank an die redaktion von
technology review für das spannende
thema noch weitere unglaubliche themen
gibt es in dem gratis hefte dass er
bekommt wenn er hier drauf klickt also
klicken und staunen würde ich mal sagen
und hier geht es weiter also darunter
mit einem anderen coolen thema von
technology review dafür auch einfach
drauf kriegen schutzhülle um das erbgut
werden wir zu superhelden bis dann
blatter